bella sui ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fan i j
oggi siamo finalmente giunti a un
traguardo incredibile ragazzetto video è
un traguardo veramente importante ci
tenevo a festeggiarlo tra virgolette con
un video più che speciale anche perché
questo è in assoluto il vino più lungo
che ho fatto veramente ragazzi voglio
ringraziarvi anche perché in
contemporanea con il centesimo video
abbiamo raggiunto circa quasi 35mila
iscritti comunque giù di lì e volevo
veramente ringraziarvi anche per questo
traguardo 35 mila iscritti in poco tempo
non me li sarei mai aspettate quindi
laga veramente grazie di cuore
ho iniziato a capire di essere seguito
volentieri dagli altri dai mi piace che
dicevo stock ogni video dai bellissimi
commenti che ricevo ad ogni video
veramente grazie ragazzi da yacht ovi
che scopre di aver fatto una foto con me
o sotto la foto con lui e non lo sapevo
ho fatto ho fatto una foto con fa vj e
non lo sapevo ma vera gavi volevo
veramente ringraziare per questo
traguardo agli incredibili
prima di partire voglio spiegarvi in che
cosa consiste questo video speciale ho
fatto un sondaggio su facebook è la
scelta più votata per il video speciale
dei 100 per il centesimo video è stato
quello di fare un mega mix di sei
diversi videogames di durata media di 10
minuti ciascuno per una durata totale di
circa un'ora divido adesso non so quanto
è uscita la durata di video comunque
dovrebbe essere circa un'oretta ho
scelto diciamo i videogames che
hanno fatto li chiamo più scalpore tra
virgolette da quando ho iniziato a fare
video non ci sono proprio tutti perché
dovevo sceglierne 6
comunque spero che vi piacciono detto
questo direi che possiamo iniziare
preparate i pop corn perché ci sarà da
divertirsi e detto questo che la
maratona cominci
quando cazzo così esagerato bene a tutti
i ragazzi non li devo rifare l'intero
ogni volta che iniziò un nuovo videogame
va beh siamo sues lander di arrivo
l'allora ragazzi volevo precisare una
cosa slider di ernst i vol
io l'ho già finito come sapete penso
tutti comunque la maggior parte per chi
lo ha già visto io svenda di harry
valloggia fatto mi dove ho già fatto
però una volta che l'ho finito è durato
mi pare tre episodi una volta che ho
finito mi avete fatto notare tutti
quanti che è praticamente slider di
harry vol
aveva un finale no oltre fino alla
sorpresa che non ho fatto perché ho
visto è una cavolata alla fine non c'è
nulla c'è soltanto una clip di due
secondi aggiunta alla fine a differenza
di quello normale quindi non l'ho fatto
perché sarebbe stato identico l'episodio
di prima però c'è un segreto is lander
di harry volo ovvero se si raccolgono
adesso vediamo perché cifra andando
se si raccoglie tre volte un manifesto
nel primo livello vero questo qui il
prologo se si lavora stessi 6 si
raccoglie se si raccoglie tre volte un
manifesto che ha appeso a un albero si
sblocca un livello segreto che
normalmente non c'è il manifesto l'ho
già preso due volte questa è la terza ho
iniziato a registrare appunto alla terza
perché se no devo fare ma che dietro 20
volte ed era al mare
ragazzi quindi ci siamo ragalo ra il
manifesto è questo qua dovrebbe
funzionare non lo so e dovrebbe
funzionare non funziona perfetto
dovrebbe tornare al menu ma non mi
funziona
ok ragazzi dovremmo essere adesso credo
ok
credo che ci siamo bene siamo tornati al
menu ok ragazzi stiava allora credo che
adesso debba funzionare allora cosa devo
fare il suo staff game
credo di sì non ne sono sicuro
praticamente l'ml o sky news file mi
sono perso poi trovarmi dipende dipende
dove cazzo di nascondi se bono so
dipende orazzo sto in botta forte porca
[ __ ] che è successo perché non c'è il
pavimento è veramente non c'è il freddo
ma non importa
e normale che sia così ho sempre fatto
tutto bene entro in casa posso entrare
anzi
buongiorno c'è la casa mancata ve ne
siete accorti che cazzo che bordello che
cazzo devo fare qui è tutto tra l'altro
giorno quindi si può vedere
fortunatamente
problema che sta lampeggiando tutto
cazzo mi sembra di essere dentro la
sirena di un'ambulanza e per caso una
nutella lampeggiante da qualche parte no
vero e allora non la prendo la guaracha
del sugo sto facendo
sto girando a caso ok che cazzo succede
a teletrasporta bene sono al piano di
sopra
sono mi sono teletrasportato cazzo ma io
lo slider adesso
beh posso uscire dalla finestra no
perché tanto non c'è prato quindi non
importano ragazzi non sto capendo cosa
sta succedendo è normale che sia così sì
penso di sì però è un po strana come
cosa si vede che hai preso delle pillole
prima di ok pazzo
siamo nel corridoio ora cioè merda
questa mi chiami st sballottando madonna
manco avessi fumato una canna cioè cosa
devo fare qui o continuare ad essere
trasportarmi giro va bene è pieno di
pagine cosa devo fare questa sinistra
rotta tra l'altro bene e che cosa dovrei
fare qui adesso devo uscire di qua non è
chiusa bene all'amico trasmessa mi piaci
voglio fare un gioco con te che cazzo è
l'enigmista
oddio è finito così era questo c'è
questo era un leader ma dai ma che
livello è io pensavo di essere diventato
lo slider perché di michele trasportava
un po ovunque
vabbè raga diciamo che questa roba non
erano dieci minuti era è un'introduzione
facciamo così va beh l'ho fatta così
almeno ha dato e mi avevate chiesto in
tanti hanno fatto lo stesso dire di
passare dopo questa breve introduzione
ai videogame di oggi dopo secoli di
dottori che non riescono a capire le
cause le malattie dei pazienti
ritorna lui a salvare il mondo e lui è
qui oggi dottor fa vj rega siamo tornati
sul surge stimulator sono imbacuccato
come un caldo della madonna questa roba
trato sta roba mi soffoca siamo tornati
su serge simulator volevo fare una
precisazione prima di iniziare me
l'avete consigliato in due miliardi di
persone ultimamente che uscito il nuovo
sorge un simulator ovvero la versione
completa perché questo è soltanto una
demo come quella che avevo giocato in
precedenza è state tranquilli che voi
avete chiesto in tantissimi tranquilli
che appena però possibilità di farlo
farò anche questo quindi aspettatevelo e
vi dovevo imbacuccate così ogni [ __ ]
molta direi ricominciare allora il
cronometro cui è partito già da un
secolo 3 2 1
iniziamo ok raga allora non mi ricordo
non mi ricordo neanche come cazzo si
gioca dalla perfetto devo riprendere un
attimo confidenza coi comandi come si
chiudono le dita ok vediamo se mi
ricordo vediamo se mi ricordo vediamo se
mi ricordo se mi ricordo
ok perfetto allora ci siamo vogliamo sta
roba inutile
dobbiamo eseguire un'operazione cazzo
allora perfetto togliamo maledizione
tagli ti porca put a va bene così
soffoca al paziente neanche ok perfetto
ci siamo benissimo c'è un caldo boia
costo merda addosso va bene un po niente
resisto allora ragazzi
la lezione precedente non dovreste
averla dimenticata quindi tutti quanti
gli apprendisti dottori prestino
attenzione perché oggi faremo un
bellissimo rimpasto
allora bisogna eseguire un trapianto di
cuore per farlo bisogna togliere tutte
le cose inutili in superficie come le
ossa e i polmoni che non servono un
cazzo allora la prima cosa che si deve
fare è togliere la radio perché c'è
musica di merda
una volta fatto questo si può passare
alle cose un po più serie allora
innanzitutto per rimuovere la parte
superficiale
bisogna prendere saldamente un attrezzo
molto ma molto leggero perché bisogna
rimuovere con delicatezza le parti
superiori del nostro paziente quindi
bisogna perché il dito medio non si
chiude non voi non è ora di mandarlo a
[ __ ] adesso cosa facciamo dopo va
bene si impugna molto saldamente quando
dico saldamente dico saldamente il
martello come potete vedere è una volta
cazzo è caduta ebbene si impugna
saldamente il martello e se il martello
si incastra nelle costole del vostro
paziente
fate finta di nulla tanto non se ne
accorge devo no mi scusi sta tentando di
impugnarlo come si deve va bene così non
importa lo teniamo così tenete il
martello così è una volta fatto questo
cercate di rimuovere con molta
moltissima calma la parte superiore del
vostro paziente perfetto no non si è
tolta qualche [ __ ] devo se ce l'ho
fatta e al martello allora il martello
cazzo mi si è incastrata la mano
rocca [ __ ] va bene allora ci siamo
tutti calmi
devo una volta fatto questo bisogna
ovviamente rimuovere tutte le cose
inutili che rimangono all'interno del
nostro paziente per i polmoni che non
servono a un cazzo dopodichè le ossa che
ovviamente anche quelle non servono una
sega no non serve una proteggere il
cuore non servono a nulla quindi i
polmoni via via anche le ossa via tutto
quanto è bisogna fare spazio per
lavorare sul cuore appunto ok vai tutto
via
ok ci dobbiamo riuscire a raja ce la
posso fare allora c'è questo pezzo
enorme che deve andare fuori dal caso
togliti porca [ __ ] toglie the ok allora
una volta che vi siete fatti sufficiente
spazio all'interno del vostro paziente
per lavorare bisogna passare alle cose
un po più diciamo delicate tra
virgolette adesso vedrete perché ho
messo le virgolette allora una volta
tolte tutte le ossa bisogna passare a
recidere i tubicini di gomma del cuore
perché quelli sono tubicini di gomma
fatta attenzione in termini scientifici
avrei tubicini di gomma che collegano al
cuore al paziente vanno rimossi con
attrezzi molto delicati e allora
prendiamo ovviamente sempre impugnando
saldamente i nostri attrezzi ma molto
saldamente andiamo a rimuovere i
tubicini di gomma inutile allora
possiamo farcela vai piano molta calma
molta calma non si vede ma sto sudando
cazzo no mi è partita la sega ok
perfetto mia andata via
sarebbe il caso dovete decidere i
tubicini di gomma e vika dell'attrezzo
principale bisogna prenderne uno molto
ma molto piccolo quindi apprestiamoci a
prendere una sega enorme è una volta
preso a questa bisogna ovviamente ma che
cazzo ok ci sarà no mi scusi non era
niente allora bisogna sempre a impugnare
saldamente i nostri attrezzi
si ok perfetto ci siamo vai possiamo
farci re alla mano brutto idiota
perfetto allora diamo a decidere i
nostri tubicini di gomma cioè possiamo
fare vai piano molto piano molto c'è
allora uno forse è andato forse allora
ce la possiamo fare vai non è difficile
porca [ __ ] abbassati si no
uno è andato perfetto è già un miracolo
ragazza possiamo fare
mai mai mai mai prestate attenzione che
queste cose dovrete ripeterle poi una
volta finito lo stage
allora ce la possiamo fare mai tagliamo
se perfetta una volta rimossi topicidi
gomma levati dal cas niente bob capitana
miwa intralciare il cuore nuovo
togliti togliti brutta stronza di una
sega cosa vuoi fare
vuoi rimorchiarli il cuore mi serve vai
via
una volta messo a ko il coltellone
bisogna passare a rimuovere il cuore
attuale una volta rimossi appunto i
tubicini di gomma quindi avviciniamoci
prendiamo il cuore gli impugniamo lo
saldamente rimuoviamo lo dall'interno
del paziente nel caso l'altro non
funzioni bisogna inserire questo quindi
appoggiamo lo molto delicatamente è una
volta preso il nuovo cuore ovvero questo
imponiamo anche quest'anno prima mi son
dimenticato un passaggio importantissimo
scusatemi raga allora è perché i
professionisti come me ogni tanto si
dimenticano abbiate pazienza e l'età
dobbiamo prendere allora togliamo tutta
sta roba che non serve un cazzo e
prendiamo i cotton fioc i cotton fioc
sono essenziali sono essenziali per la
sopravvivenza del nostro paziente perché
il cotton fioc puliscono all'interno del
nostro paziente e quindi tutti i batteri
e tutte quante ne tutti quanti difetti
all'interno il nostro paziente andranno
corretti mini cotton fioc oltre a pulire
le orecchie servono anche a pulire
l'interno del paziente una volta rimosso
il cuore via il martello direi che ci
siamo per quanto ancora marte
no merda mi è caduto il martello allora
se vi cade per caso un martello
all'interno vi ricordo che potrete
coprirlo con un qualcosa in modo che il
paziente non si accorga di quello che è
successo
ragazzi siamo in conclusione direi di
passare al l'impianto del cuore nuovo
allora lo si prende sempre saldamente è
una volta fatto bisogna dare una
strigliata perché ovviamente i cuori
nuove vanno avete presente quando
comprate le cose nuove che ci hanno
profumo di nuovo no e bisogna diciamo un
po lavarle quindi in questo caso non
abbiamo la lavatrice ma sbatacchiando un
po di quelli la dovrebbe diciamo
elasticizzati a dovere una volta preso
il cuore nuovo bisogna appoggiarlo
delicatamente all'interno del nostro
paziente è una volta fatto bisogna
impiantarlo dandogli una botta secca
ok cazzo mi ha volato il martello
perfetto allora
di avvicinarlo e basta ce la possiamo
fare
togliti brutto stop che cazzo c'è un
osso che mio mi ostruisce il passaggio
maledetto l'osso deve togliersi togliti
brutto bastardo perché sei in mezzo che
cazzo ci no no maledizione non è posti
sorgere complete
ok perfetto c'è l'abbiamo fatto ragazzi
sorge di time 9 minuti e 49 secondi 10
secondi in anticipo quindi ragazzi il 3
il trapianto è completo spero che
abbiate capito che la lezione vi sia
servita fatemi levare sta roba che vi
sta soffocando porca [ __ ]
ok era cosa oscena porca [ __ ]
mio dio sto sudando cazzo va beh
volevo soltanto dirvi che sar john
simulator quello ufficiale uscirà ciò è
già uscito ma lo farò io il problema
possibile con questa roba è quindi raga
ma aspettatevi di tutto perché questo
era soltanto trapianto di cuore ma nella
versione ufficiale ci sono altri
trapianti che saranno una figata assurda
quindi raga aspettatelo perché presto
arriverà quindi laga con l'operazione di
oggi abbiamo finito e direi di passare
al prossimo videogame poker a gas chiamo
su chi è mario il primo non quello che
sto facendo attualmente ovvero quello
che ho già finito allora laga voglio
provare a fare una sfida pazza ma
veramente pazza voglio provare a finire
cat mario i dieci fottuti minuti
cercando di ricordarmi in più o meno
come era come era fatto quali erano i
trabocchetti voglio provare a finirli in
dieci minuti
incredibile quindi mi servirà il brutto
stronzo che vi terrà compagnia per dieci
fottuti minuti devo riuscire a farcela
raga un'impresa epocale se ci riesco
cioè finirlo in dieci minuti una cosa
impossibile però ci provo by allora
prendo il secondo fiato perché sarà una
corsa assurda
ok senza tagli senza niente vai ce la
posso fare
32 una via già partito se ok allora ce
la posso fare vai vai vai vai vai se ce
la posso fare dichiara game posto non mi
ricordo
porca [ __ ] partiamo di merda non mi
ricordo a raga non mi ricordo le
trappole cazzo
ok ce la posso fare non è impossibile
non è impossibile se si è una cosa
assurda
non mi ricordo allagano mi ricordo le
trappole cazzo numeri
dio mio stavo scrivendo to dragan ok
perfetto mi sa che non ci riesca ma non
perdo d'animo quanto siamo 30 secondi
cazzo ce la posso fare la gara
impossibile ma ce la posso fare
non ci posso credere che in dieci minuti
non riesco a fare un cazzo se ce l'ho
fatta
ok allora piano piano piano di mandare
di sopra vai vai se c'è grande la
bandiera se non è più la bandiera fa
vigeva chi se ne fotteva andiamo avanti
ok porca [ __ ]
la breda bandiera l'ho presa sei
perfetta dalla faccia posso fare vai vai
vai vai mai muoviti che scade il tempo
ma cazzo
raga e la sfida con più ansia che
abbiamo rifatto
no perché mi dimentico che già il cazzo
di kobo un'edizione muoviti cazzone
suonare prima che finisce il tempo che a
quanto siamo un minuto cazzo è troppo
tardi
ok sto andando troppo in fretta se ok
allora da camicia possiamo fare vai vai
vai vai vai se sì allora devo farli
fuori tutti quanti se vai vai vai bye
bye bye bye bye vai bene siamo alla fine
dopo di questa parte impossibile non ci
credo non ci credo
si no no non ci posso credere non si
possono non ci voglio credere
non ci voglio credere sono morto ce
l'avevo fatta cazzo quanto era passato
un minuto e quaranta non ci credo ce la
potevo fare era non era difficile non
era difficile non era difficile
maledizione
ok vai cia posso fare dai non ci posso
credere che non ci riesco
la loggia ha fatto una volta non posso
perdere dai ce la posso fare dieci
minuti non sono non sono così pochi ma
veramente sono un cazzo ciao women in
totale ci ha promesso siano sei o sette
ora a finirlo normalmente in dieci
minuti è un'impresa titanica ma ce la
posso fare se ce l'ha fatta il primo
livello laica ce ne sono quattro state
tranquilli
intanto cammino mi si sono sposate le
cuffie vai ce la posso questo non me lo
ricordo cosa devo fare qui devo tipo non
mi ricordo cazzo non mi ricordo non mi
ricordo devo non dovevo fare così questo
è sicuro kat
ok mi sono ricordato mi sono ricordato
vai vai vai col tango due minuti e mezzo
vai ce la faccio ce la faccio è una cosa
un po strada fare tipo così si ok dove
andati sotto l'onda di sé ok grande
salto che grandissimo visto ricordato
dice una trappola allora qua non c'erano
delle spine sul terzo sulla terza
colonna ok grande link questo era già al
secondo episodio raga quindi sono già
andate abbastanza avanti devo ok vai vai
se poi c'è il pedobear devo saltarlo
devo saltare ecco perfetto vai si no
cazzo quello lì non l'avevo mai visto
neanche prima della prima volta che ho
fatto che mario merda
ok ce la posso fare adesso so dove lo
sbaglio
devo riuscire a far fuori sti stronzi se
riesco magari se ok bene ce la posso
fare
dai il pedobear che mi dà fastidio devo
saltarlo se grandissimo la bandiera
madonna mia incredibile non ci posso
credere che ce la faccio dai dai dai dai
del è madonna dolci credo non ci
vogliono chimica se riesco a fare questa
mimì mi abbraccio da solo non so come
faccio questa la couleur haga dipende
dipende da come cade prefetto è caduto
forse di merda o forse no sì non ci
credo non ci voglio madonna non devo
prendere punti madonna lo sto prendendo
ok devo riuscire a fare sto punto
impossibile se riesco a far questo
arrivo al terzo livello in quanto i tre
minuti che lei in quattro minuti va bene
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai se non
ci credo non ci voglio credere
vai così madonna mia santa adesso lo
fare un salto della madonna
se ci voglio chiamato e pedobear vai via
non ci credo raga non ci credo non ci
credo non ci credo
no ce l'ho fatta sì quando quanto siamo
quattro minuti e 25
siamo arrivati davanti non ci posso che
allora qua devo prendere sta roba si
devo saltare qui sopra ok adesso
dovrebbe arrivare non dovevano arrivare
alle stelle mi pare una roba del genere
non mi ricordo malissimo cazzo
cos'è successo io mi ricordavo che
doveva mi armi stupravano tipo delle
stelle una roba del genere se prendiamo
sta roba che devo prendere per forza non
arrivano mostrano si vede che è diverso
ricordavo diverso fai allora devo
saltare qui ok questo me lo ricordavo
raga questa è la parte è molto più
difficile di tutto il resto
ok bene devo non mi riconoscevo
prenderlo punto interrogativo devo
prenderlo no quanto sono cinque minuti
mai non lo prendo andiamo avanti la
bandiera se raga che tu mario in dieci
minuti sfido chiunque
ok non sfida un cazzo di nessuno perché
non ce la faccio se continuo così ma
l'inizio hanno preso la bandiera ma non
devo non devo cantare vittoria perché
ancora ne manca
mica questo questa è la lo stronzo che
mi tirava in aria ce la posso fare
allora quando tira su qualcosa no ok
cosa devo fare qui madonna
ce l'ho fatta devo adottano indietro
vedere dai 76 ok mi ricordo st parte
seguì il dito perfetto
ok bene un'altra bandiera non ci voglio
credere non ci voglio credere se ce l'ho
fatta
ok ragazza parte era impossibile stava è
infatti come non detto sono partito di
merda maledizione sei minuti
muovete laga si accettano scommesse
scrivete nei commenti ce la faccio non
ce la faccio se continuo così non ce la
faccio
anche perché ho sbagliato non dovevo
fare così maledizione
raga questa è la parte più difficile
sicuro perché cazzo però se mi dimentico
di saltare maledizione non ce la farò
mai quanto siano cazzo devo riuscire st
parte raga impossibile vi giuro
ci avevo messo perché mi dimentico di
saltare maremma ma porca [ __ ]
devo non posso farlo mi serve superman
cazzo quello che faccio fuori all'inizio
se non lo se non lo faccio fuori subito
devo saltarci dopo sopra impossibile vai
vai vai se se ce l'ho fatta vai adesso
ce la posso fare se non ci credo non ci
credo e non ci voglio che ci avevo messo
un secolo anche tagliando ci avevo messo
un secolo ce l'ho fatta
raga un miracolo è un miracolo che sette
minuti quasi cosa devo fare qui non mi
ricordo non importa vai vai vai così vai
così a simin che anche questo era il
prossimo ad onna raga in possesso gioco
impossibile tutto ma no no no no non ci
credo anche amica se ce la faccio forza
parte mi devono fare santo quanto manca
alla fine che quand è che finiva che
mario che non mi ricordo
minchia nomi ricorrono finiva cazzo no
no no no nick annuncia farò mai più
l'ho fatto prima non ce la farò mai più
sette minuti dai dai dai dai dai
se ragazzo un ansia addosso che non
manco is lander quando l'avevo finito
per la prima volta manco is lander
c'avevo stanzia cazzo
niente niente niente niente maledizione
non ce la farò mai
quindici sono arrivato a sto punto con
15 morti è impossibile ce l'aveva ma
niente ma porca [ __ ] st parte non ce
la farò quanto no la gara devo darmi una
morsa ma che cazzo allora saltiamo sto
punto di merda si se ce la posso fare
mica mi viene anche da ruttare
fantastico proprio il momento adatto se
dai dolci che vai così allora quadro
saltare qui ok dove andare avanti se si
ok st parte non me la ricordo porca
[ __ ] nomi c'era un qualcosa qui si
infatti me lo ricordavo devo saltare no
devo correre tipo devo poi no no magari
doda cazzo devo rifarmi tuttora camicia
la bandiera non ce la farò mai a
prenderla questo punto non ce la farò
mai
non ce la farò quanto 8 minuti la
ragazza ce la posso fare mancano 8
minuti mi mancano due livelli
devo devo riuscire a farcela adesso
senza morire vai niente come quanto 18
morti maledizione 18 fottute morti ce la
faccio è troppo poco dieci minuti almeno
15 niente niente
niente niente niente devo ammettere come
se non voglio neanche una volta l'avesse
da adesso in avanti ce la posso fare ma
non devo proprio morire dai muoviti
cazzo muoviti che scada il tempo la
riedizione dai devo saltare no si grande
grande grande grande
si ok ok tutti calmi tutti i calmissimi
ok
devo fare sta parte impossibile come
faccio se devo saltare c'è la nuvola
rischio non mi ricordo non mi ricordo
come vota non mi ricordo come avevo
fatto maledizione come cazzo avevo fatto
a saltare quel punto impossibile non
posso farcela non ho perso
definitivamente ho perso non ci sono
arrivato fino al quarto episodio mi pare
era arrivato al quarto episodio a sto
punto quindi ho fatto un casino è però
non non basta per arrivare alla fine
cioè dieci minuti sono troppo pochi di
ieri finirla qui perché il tempo è
scaduto
non ce l'ho fatta proprio l'ultima volta
ma tanto non ce la faccio
se riesco a farlo da qui in avanti senza
morire lo faccio anche tutto ma non ce
la farò mai
ok ci siamo adesso muoio cazzo sta parte
infattibile vai mai
ok ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta ok raga
non sono morte impossibile ce la posso
fare
voglio provarci vai vai vai così non ci
credo ok raga sono passati dieci minuti
ma voglio provare senza morire neanche
una volta anche se non ci riuscirò c'è
dopo tutto sto casino qui ero arrivato a
sto punto qua è praticamente sono alla
fine raga non manca un cazzo cioè ero
arrivato porca [ __ ] era arrivato
maledizione devo farmi lanciare da sto
tipo
ok guardate un attimo che se riesco se
ci sono riuscito
ok sono arrivato lago finito che mario
con qualche secondo di ritardo
maledizione porto siamo undici minuti
non ci credo
l'ho finito con un minuto non ci voglio
credere
per un minuto maledizione o finito che
mario in dieci minuti praticamente
soltanto che non ce l'ho fatta nel tempo
prestabilito peccato perché veramente
aver fatto undici minuti è già stato un
qualcosa di epico
non mi era mai successo non mi succederà
mai più
anche perché non ci giocherò mai più
hackett mario uno almeno
devo finire l'altro purtroppo ma vabbè
vabbè ragazzi vedi concludere qui con
cat mario e direi di passare al prossimo
ok ragazzi siamo siamo sud the rake
black assai lum direct black casa in un
videogame indiehorror laga che mi avete
consigliato ma da un bel pezzo cene se
avevo giocato a the rake hostel che era
il primo the rake ed è stato traumatico
è una volta che ho giocato a quello una
volta avevo finito di giocarci mi
avevate consigliato di giocare appunto a
the red black casa in un che è
praticamente la stessa cosa
soltanto in un'altra mappa per chi non
conoscesse direi che adesso ve lo spiego
un attimo è un videogame molto simile a
slang di molto simile tra virgolette nel
senso che c'è da il sangue a differenza
di slider qua c'è del sangue
e vabbè è un videogame dove si si parte
in una zona non si sa perché quindi fin
qui tutto normale come al solito è lo
scopo di questo gioco non si sa nel
senso che bisogna prendere capitana che
cazzo glorie ok è stato oddio ma c'è
ancora non c'è nessuno b o addio è stato
traumatico che cazzo è mica questa era
una scena da horror raga questo la metto
in un montaggio di sicuro
ok e volevo di stavo dicendo che lo
scopo di questo gioco e trovare un
qualcosa che non so cosa c'è nell'altro
direi che era una specie di pagine una
roba del genere
bisognava prenderlo e tornare all'inizio
ovvero all'inizio proprio cioè da dove
siamo partiti
quindi bisogna trovare st pagine o
quello che è e tornare all'inizio qua
perché c'è del sangue dietro sta porta
oggi è dentro una donna mestruata e io
ci ho paura ad entrarci è tanto non si
possono aprire le porte quindi chi se ne
fotte non c entra andiamo avanti a
quanto siamo a quasi due minuti bene rag
allora bisogna riuscire a trovare st
pagina che presumo sia una pagina anche
perché non lo so è tornare indietro a
mano in dieci minuti perché sono devo
cambiare gameplay allora qua mi dovete
spiegare perché ci sono dei gesti tutti
quanti vicini cos'è una cagata di gruppo
se non lo capisco va beh
qua non c'è nulla che torniamo indietro
benissimo allora laga e traumatico come
il gioco e trauma raga tronato adesso
che mi viene anche in mente darei più
penso che sia tra tutti i videogame che
ho provato finora
penso che sia videogame che in generale
faccio a prendere i colpi più forti
perché aspetti mai quando quella fare ti
appare ok ok c'è il cesso fammi fare una
cagata assurda perché mi sto pagando
addosso
ok
ebbene tratto perché sono in piedi
successo non lo so è andato via è andato
via
bene raga dicevo direi che se riesco a
finire cosa è sta roba cos'è mio dio
cosa sono cos'è una camera di tortura
cos'è manicomio volevo dire volevo dire
appunto chiederei se riesco a finire la
frase ai videogame che penso che faccia
prendere gli infarti più assurdi perché
quello di compare quella fare ti compare
in un modo che non c'è non c'è nessuno
che lo scomparire così non ce n'è subito
game che in cui compaia così mostro
maledizione non ce n'è nessuno nessuno
questo è il peggiore perché ti compare
con un effetto sonoro e con una c'è in
un modo talmente immediato che prendersi
colpa inevitabile comunque vabbè andiamo
avanti siamo due minuti e mezzo siamo a
3 minuti e mezzo ovunque aiuto misto fra
che ci pazzo fatti sono da chi cazzo
cazzo di casino rugger ovunque cena non
ne basta uno ce ne vogliono quattro sono
non va bene e andiamo di qua ragazzo mio
dio è una cosa traumatica
andiamo via che posto dove sono andato
ad esso ha preso un'altra strada si che
cazzo di strada è questa raga sto
sudando vi giuro
sto suda c'è non si vede ma sto sudando
c'è cazzo
[Applauso]
lo state sentendo anche voi ke kazzo est
ha voce
sì ci mancava soltanto quello che urla
il cazzo è ragazze 1 che urla e mi sta
dando parecchio far madonna che
corridoio
ebbene non capisco dove da dove
provengono le urla
sinceramente neanche mi interessa
madonna c'è la manina loro genito che
amici aprendo il tetano solo a guardarlo
cazzo cioè ma che cazzo dove siamo
raga allora calmiamoci un secondo
dobbiamo capire dove dobbiamo andare
perché se non capiamo cosa dobbiamo fare
siamo a 5 minuti e non so neanche porca
[ __ ] non so neanche cosa devo fare
è un problema non ce ne sono
raga mitragliano è come se non bastasse
gioco già fa paura di suo in più mi
trovano anche adesso voi mi spiegate che
cazzo di senso a questa stanza ma dove
dovrebbe portarmi ma no ma mi prendete
per il c io ho fatto un chilometro e
mezzo per ritrovarmi qui c'è ma che
cazzo ma mi prendete per il culo non ci
voglio credere io me ne devo tornare
indietro da una stanza completamente
vuota non scherziamo
c'è ma mio dio che cosa ha fatto fare
tutto sto pezzo vabbè lasciamo cos'è
hanno niente sono piastrelle maledizione
devo tornare indietro porca [ __ ] cioè
caso ma per tornare indietro ci impiego
due ore cioè come faccio
ma non poco resta roba non può occorre
cioè non possono i personaggini
videogiochi horror non possono
fottutamente correre perché hanno
mangiato troppi fottuti hamburger e non
lo capirò mai perché minchia una volta
che guidò usain bolt mai niente niente
sempre un obeso vabbè facciamo finta di
niente
sei minuti e mezzo dai dai dai cazzo dai
cazzo che devo vincere prima dello
scadere del tempo dove devo andare qua
siamo all'inizio praticamente si sono
tornato all'inizio non ho concluso un
cazzo
ok si sentivano le voci sentono le voci
non mi piace che qualcuno di sangue
omv dio si sentono le voci e non mi
piacciono che cazzo allora andiamo di
qua diamo di qua perché tanto è l'unico
appunto perché c'è una colonna in mezzo
c'è l'ho passato di qua no non ci ho
passato tante benson progressi sono
progressi calcio e devo trovare
assolutamente qualcosa aiutatemi datemi
una mano ditemi dove devo andare anche
se meno di te ormai aver già registrato
video quindi non serve un cazzo ma
aiutatemi se potete
perché non so dove andare tra l'altro è
pieno livraga pieno di strade non ce la
farò mai è troppo pieno di roba come
faccio di trovare quello che devo trovi
non so neanche cosa c'è più in teoria
potrebbe staccare una piastrella e
portarla all'inizio magari è quello che
devo fare ragazzo che ci che ho detto a
vedermi giocare a sta roba
ma a me non mi piace giocarci non mi
piace che cazzo sta facendo sistan
stuprando state pisciando in gruppo io
me ne vado tolgo il disturbo grazie
mille
si no non mi seguite mentre non guardano
state pure lì pisciate come volete io
non voglio guardarvi io me ne vado mi
faccio i cazzi miei
no speriamo che non debba tornare
indietro adesso perché mi prenderei un
infarto ok siamo a 8 minuti ce la posso
fare
raga credete in me in due minuti devo
prendere ok ho sbagliato strada
porca [ __ ] ma si può
era l'altra cazzo ce n'erano due ragazzo
a 50 per cento di possibilità sbaglio
sempre strada non ce la farò mai
ok beh mi fai passare
sorpreso muro bravo bravo bravo bravo
realizzale bravo bravo per ok no stai
fermo cazzo corre corre come un idiota
ok sono due adesso si sdoppiano c'è la
tecnica del della moltiplicazione o che
tipo naruto vai
vai vai vai così c'è un tavolo a caso
devo trovare qualcosa di temi che la
quanto manca quasi un minuto cazzo
devo trovare qualcosa dai non ci credono
credere che non trovo niente no no no no
non ci credo
un ciclo sono ripartito all'inizio sono
ripartito all'inizio
raga non ce lo fa va bene ormai tanto
non ce la faccio in un minuto a trovare
quello che devo trovare e tornare
indietro non ce la faccio quindi direi
di concludere qui vi ringrazio per
avermi consigliato anche questo
splendido gioco perché ovviamente ma
quando non l'avevate consigliato dovevo
farlo quindi grazie mille so che mi
volete bene vi voglio bene anch'io e
direi di passare al prossimo gameplay
perfetto ragazzi siamo siamo su happy
meals primo videogame della sfilza che
andrà a giocare vi ricordo raga che non
potrò tagliare neanche una volta perché
già i giochi durano dieci minuti a testa
se mi metto a tagliare alla fine durano
30 secondi
qui vi devo riuscire a non tagliare
nulla dalle su in avanti impresa
impossibile però ci proviamo lo stesso
die ora andiamo subito sono parliamo da
tempo mystery island
non ho idea di che cosa siano i livelli
vanno a caso raga non taglio non ecco i
miei soliti video ci provo
siamo con gli orchi suo padre vai
andiamo così a brucia proviamoci sono
già madonna che mito che mito
devo riuscire a fare una cosa decenza e
quindi spero di non morire troppe volte
che backflip iniziamo da dio fantastico
non è neanche un mostro perfetto non c'è
nessuno la cosa diventa traumatica
perché se cado adesso devo iniziato a
capo ok
dovevo andare lì sotto c'è una rock
cerda da ok sono vivo la rotta didietro
nicaise minchiata ma sono vivo ok
raga adesso mi dovete spiegare come
cazzo continuo senza braccia e senza
ruota modo sarò comunque là davanti
oddio cosa cazzo sto facendo
beh ragazzo soltanto la ruota davanti è
un problema questo perché come cazzo
faccia continua cosa cazzo fa dov'è liuc
dove è finita oddio dov'è finito il look
e ragga è sparito cioè quando quando c'è
il momento di cambiare a ruota che lo
deve fare lui quel maledetto non c'è mai
ma ho finito lo stesso
ok primo livello andato completamente a
caso non mi chiedete che cazzo di senso
aveva non lo so cambiamolo gravity test
ok ci siamo siamo con questo personaggio
non credo di averlo mai usato
ah sì devo andare avanti senza farmi
schiacciare che ce la posso fare vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai vai via st diventa
ogni addio
la cai bambina andato perfetto la
mammina vista non credevo di essere
arrivati alla fine che culo ok allora il
secondo è andato incredibile ce la sto
facendo senza fare troppe figure di
merda mille visto dai non mi piacciono
tanto proviamo con gli in posti come vai
è un impulsivo senza steve allora non è
un impossible è universo non ho mai
fatto questo cioè doriani in passivo
sono tutti qua che scherzo è ovvio ovvio
cos'è sta o mio dio c'è questa ha un
cazzo di senso sto li vedevo
praticamente passare a me ci mandò gli
occhio a [ __ ] vai o no ma ndo cazzo
riuscito al maledetto stronzo sarai un
serpente di merda ma non riuscirai
mangiarmi maledizione ha vinto il geom
andato prima gli occhi ha vinto lui ce
la fate mi capita male eh vai grande gli
occhio dai che ci arriva
sono riuscito a riprendere al volo luca
alla fine ce l'ho fatta allora laga
questo è un impossible ma non ha nulla a
che vedere con quelli di steve rainbow
barbour anno ok devo mettermi alla prova
con gli a questo l'ho fatto il quello
dei marshmallow vai ce la posso fare
quel mastello nostro aperto ma se
vincerò questa ragazza nuova posizione
di yoga credo anche la bcc si mette
cazzo è bene proviamo a ripartire allora
devo mandare a magari prima uk e che
amministra e tutti gli arpioni ok a
malaga in pezzi di alto livello ma non
si può fare
non si può fare semplicemente perché
oddio c'è che cazzo raga non ha non ha
senso perché non ce la puoi fare io vado
al massimo per un attimo ho pensato che
gli occhi potesse farcela che maledetto
illuso che so ho vinto con le gambe le
mie gambe raga sono più forti di me
ok è già un traguardo mi accontento
importante accontentarsi va bene così è
andato anche questo accordo siamo
quattro minuti perfetto devo resistere
altri cinque minuti senza spararmi
figure basket ball game questo mi ispira
devo cercare di far cane lo zio che figo
maledizione riuscirà a fare da sé cura 1
l
c'è anche con la testa maledizione è
grande ma dovevi farlo perché veramente
no il canestro e dall'altra parte idiota
che cazzo dai gemelli non ci piglia poi
banco al basket o di cos'era
ma come sempre la palla coi piedi spiega
me lo spiega me non sono traguardi
questi alla fine perché se non riesci a
un bel canestro con la palla buttati nel
canestro mi sembra giusto che cazzo di
livello stupido fate mica andiamo su
sono sword trova e ci vuole lo sguardo
trovo della giornata se non è bello
questo cazzone diverso dai soliti guarda
gli occhi che si diverte sull'altalena
maledizione l'ho mancato fantastico c'è
come non detto il padre grande il padre
di giochi che assassina suo figlio
sull'altalena e devo riuscire a beccare
il tipo in alto mica impossibile invece
l'ho preso invece no cazzo
devo andare di sopra cosa anno ho vinto
ho vinto cosa che casa devo fare qui mi
sto finendo a cena o dio cioè non ho già
che sballato si è fatto di coca devo
buttarlo giù l'ho mancato cazzo cazzo
sono dio
oddio è un'invasione the walking ciak
sono tutti qui vai giù ma i giorni ma
che mi ucciderò cazzo scendi di ormai è
di grande di se ce la posso fare di mica
è finita
no la gamba cazzo cosa devo fare qui
sono rimasto bloccato merda cosa devo
fare
raga mi sono bloccato ma no ma perché
perché il suo blog ma che palle dovrei
farmi tutto per un bug di merda alla
radio che il primo va bene non è neanche
è morto ma non è caduto il padre va bene
la bimba qui nonno chuck non sa che lo
lascio brutti ma che prima è morto non
si sa come va e cognizione mica come ho
fatto a prenderlo quello di prima
impossibile è rimasta una spada ti prego
che culo però gravissimo che culo
assurdo cielo guardate come cazzo è
caduto il tipo di prima comunque tutto
all'indietro sembra quella di the grudge
ce la possiamo fare vai nonno ciak
se ce la posso fare devo cadere
a cadere come ho fatto prima a cadere
impossibile ok vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai l'ultima sparse vai ce la posso
non ti spaccare le gambe
si ok cos'è questo sembra l'esultanza
per un gol ce l'ho fatta
ok era la fine praticamente potevamo
anche smetterla ma non importa siglerà
ragali stiamo provando tutti c'è
incredibile in genere quando registro è
più vis che faccio due miliardi di tagli
e perché non trovo ai livelli giusti ma
stavolta ce la stiamo facendo
diciamo che gli sto trovando abbastanza
decenti vai ce la possiamo fare col
glass ok come si chiama non mi ricordo
non me ne fotte niente andiamo avanti
devo caricare di brutto li odio rai e
livelli quegli specchi però perché non
riesco mai a quei vetri che con gli
specchi vabbè mica se dovessi spaccare
uno specchio così al secondo ci avrei
due miliardi di anni di sfiga ma non
importa vai avanti
vai avanti ce la puoi fare maledizione
capi di vetro vittima lo sfondo a vetri
vai vai così vai così vai morendo alla
fine ok va bene così questo non mi è
piaciuto maroni bb sting cos'è questo mi
ispira nome andiamo con con steve che
ancora non l'ho fatto
youtube facebook maicon youtube dai con
youtube
capite perché io taglio i livelli quando
faccio è pierce che cazzo di bello era
che senso ha
ma dai ma che cazzo fatemi fare una roba
decente con steve prima che finisca il
tempo quando mi mancano 99 per cento
imposti col by ce la faccio grandissimo
per fa vj hem io sto livello era lo
stesso che ho fatto con i marshmallow
c'è i miei livelli riescono arrivare in
top nelle classifiche di happy meals
cesta cosa è impossibile grazie per chi
l'ha fatto critiche rei di andare avanti
con i marshmallow non ce l'avevo fatta
quindi se ci riesco adesso mi incazzo ok
byte mica ci sto riuscendo infatti cazzo
il sono rimasto bloccato per fortuna se
no mi incazzavo perché mi sono dovuto
mangiare il prof
tutti far meglio in quella volta odio
questo impossibile ragazzi l'unico
livello imporsi perché non riesco a fare
con steve è l'unico che è dedicato a me
ma si può ma letizia non possono
riuscire a fare un mio livello dai cazzo
ma steve ma ho poi riuscì ma forse ce la
facciamo
forse ce la facciamo prima del tempo
quanto rimane pochi secondi by step by
step
no ma dai non ci credo madonna mia
santissima non possono ricevere cazzo
raga non possono riuscirci sta scadendo
il tempo maledizione allora io non me ne
vado avanti non ci riesco porta
non è possibile dai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai se ho puntato giulio ok ho
buttato giù le mine è già un traguardo
devo riuscire a non farvi uccidere da
gli arpioni manca un cazzo dai che ce la
faccio mancano 23 secondi [ __ ] non
ci riesco a livello di merda
chi l'ha fatto maledizione è troppo
difficile ci rinuncia
vai vai vai vai vai vai oddio oddio cosa
sto facendo
vai steve vai steve ce la puoi fare
lavora gli addominali fai un salto della
madonna
vai si no nos timide lui può riprendere
ancora poco poi riprendere poco
dai dai dai dai dai se l'ho ripreso la
ripresa non in possesso di nuovo del
poco ce la posso fare
senza gambe chi se ne fotte vai steve
vai
avete presente i pescatori di braccia no
neanche io però mi hanno pescato un
braccio ma cazzo ma dai [ __ ] sono
ancora vivo
il problema è che non posso usare
pochezza abbraccia [ __ ] che a
livello maledizione chi è che l'ha fatto
voglio saperlo è impossibile l'unico
imposti ball che non riesco a finire
l'unico è un livello dedicato a me non
ci credo vabbè raga io la chiudo qui con
happy with direi passare al prossimo
gameplay
ok ragazzi amo su ice ve lo ricordate un
videogame indiehorror anche questo
praticamente raga ice è un video game
nel quale bisogna raccogliere 20 sacchi
di qualcosa che non mi ricordo cosa
prima che ti prenda una specie di donna
ombra una roba del centro e l'altro vedo
che l'hanno anche aggiornato la l'ultima
volta che l'ho giocato va bene direi di
iniziare alla raga io spero vi
ricordiate i gatti meglio geo dio
oddio ma l'ha cambiato tantissimo e
diverso l'ultima volta bello caso allora
raga
andiamo a giocare anche alla versione
aggiornata possibile che c'è anche
qualcosa di nuovo per chi ha visto il
vecchio episodio lo faccio semplicemente
perché aveva riscosso un bel po di
successo me lo ricordo
quindi lo rifaccio volentieri allora già
tanto che diverso dal primo questo il
primo sacchetto è andato alla raga per
chi non avesse visto il primo episodio
vecchio vecchio diciamo procede door to
open ok sta cosa già non c'era la la
luminosità non l'ha cambiata vedo bene
dai diverso l'ultimo push the door to
open che cazzo vuoi vicino ordinare
testa a ok perfetto ci siamo ebbene
siamo già in queste neville paciock
queste a porta che vedete qui è l'ultima
cioè quella che devo raggiungere e per
raggiungerla devo raccogliere appunto 20
sacchetti di quelli che avete visto
prima appunto
vabbè ci siamo ok qua ci sono gli occhi
adesso sono preparato e so cosa mi
servono
ebbene allora dove siamo mi sono già
perso nei fornelli
ok ci siamo qua c'è il frigo ovviamente
dov'è la nutella
lo dico anche se ho fatto indigestione
vabbè pazienza c'è la tipa comunque si
vede che hanno cambiato qualcosa da capa
che mi ricordavo che mi saltava addosso
ho trovato la chiave dei sotterranei
tali software ha sì ci sono dei
sotterranei ma la chiave non serviva mi
ricordo perché col mio braccio ci
arrivava a quel cancello poi lo vedrete
e vabbè siamo a cinque studenti stiamo
già andando benissimo non c'è nessuno
quindi va bene
cazzo è più facendo l'ultima volta
ricordo che la più difficile va bene
così meno male o avete sentito che cazzo
è sentito formale ma letizia ok 6 su 20
va bene dove cazzo è la tipa voglio
capire e di sotto è perfetto
vai vai vai prima che salga vai vai vai
vai prendi questo mai corri e qui sotto
cazzo aiuto oddio oddio il pd o gaza
torrido cos'è
oddio santissimo e diverso da prima oh
cazzo questo è veramente più paurosa di
prima prima era un ombra questo addio
una testa benissimo anche era gabbiamo
appurato che è completamente diverso è
molto più macabro cazzo con una testa
che vuole molto più pauroso ho già
trovato la chiave dei sotterranei che
culo e va beh penso che sia appena
passata perché ho sentito un rumore e
credo sia lei però non vedo nessuno va
bè noi andiamo avanti perfetto ad
allagare inquietante da morire molto
diverso da prima vi giuro
se ve lo ricordate c'è avreste capito
anche voi che completamente tra l'altro
quando ci sono più i gatti che ballano
tra l'altro perché dentro forno c'era un
gatto che si muoveva gli hanno tolti non
ci sono piegati raga peccato pazienza mi
erano simpatici perché se me la ritrovo
davanti all'improvviso non è un bello
spettacolo a fatemi capire se 18 di
sopra cazzo corri e muoviti corri no ma
si può ma non ci voglio credere ma come
cazzo a tutti poteva essere ovunque
sulle scale ma che cazzo di sfiga ma si
può
maledizione non ce la farò mai
a quanto si sa ho dimenticato di mettere
anche il cronometro fantastico sono un
genio
e vabbè raga ce la devo fare stavolta è
quella buona me lo sento
prendiamo questo che vai subito vai vai
e adesso cosa ce n'è un altro qui vai
così
ok sta arrivando ci siamo
raga scusatemi però e ho avuto sfiga
raga una cosa incredibile treno preside
sono buon punto ok che ci sono già stato
che perfetto vai di qua allora l'altro
sacchetto non c'è perché siamo a tre ok
perfetto allora prendiamo il sacchetto
vediamo dove sta stronza e al piano di
sopra
a meno che non scenda dovrei essere a
posto e noi andiamo subito di sotto che
vai vai di software sotto i corpi con
ricordi brutto corri corri stronzo
dobbiamo entrare in una porta così ed
raitre entra in 33 entra entra corri
maledetto se se ce l'ho fatta
ok prendiamo questo o un altro sacchetto
fantastico la 5 su 20 e 18 cazzo me lo
sento di sotto dove cazzo e di sopra
bene
esci cazzo ok raga allora e di sopra
approfittiamone per prendere tutto raga
spero di riuscirci veramente perché dato
che ho dieci minuti di tempo madonna che
topone ma quella roba vibra soltanto
quando è vicina perché non l'ho capita
sa cosa mi sa di no perché non è vicina
eppure vibrano le cose va bene siamo a 9
su 20 a metà 10 10 10 ok ce n'era
un'altra qui sopra mi ricordo ma non c'è
più
dove cazzo è la tipa sta salendo dove
dove cazzo è ancora di sopra perfetto
ragazzi siamo in teoria dovrei andarci
io di sopra cazzo ok ok ok stai ferma
che sono tremando anch'io cazzo dove
dov'è andato a finire e ancora di no sta
andando bene è andata con ricordi se mi
muovo ce la faccio
se mi muovo ce la faccio corri corri
corri corri corri carico ricordi ti
prego fa che ci al no non ce la fa già
aiuta cazzo no torniamo indietro con i
visitatori con ricordi maledetto stronza
entra entra o milvio dove dov'è andato a
finire dove egli ciò è qui so
prima ho trovato tutto adesso che
ripartono l'ho trovato nulla
fantastico partenza da dio spero di non
trovarne ho subito sono sarebbe il colmo
no perché ne era capace
dobbiamo ritrovare tutto allora è un
altro sacchetto perfetto
dobbiamo capire dove all'inizio così
almeno stiamo tranquilli
fatemi prendere un attimo l'occhio che
era di qua non c'è più perfetto file
vediamo a dover credo che sia ok al
prefetto piano di sopra quindi possiamo
stare tranquilli
raga è più difficile di prima prima era
una stronzata il confronto e ci avevo
messo dei secoli
adesso che è più difficile non sono
anche se ce la faccia probabilmente no
però va beh proviamoci lo stesso andiamo
avanti sperando che non mi spunti
all'improvviso di sopra di sotto
dobbiamo scegliere andiamo lì sotto
sicuro che di sopra tanto come non detto
ma che cazzo ma si può avere così tanta
sfiga vai di sopra accordi brutto
stronzo
corri dobbiamo entra in una porta a casa
entra in 30 mentre nel cesso me lo
ricordo che al cesso sei ok dai miei
ragazzi trovati ok che cacciano perfetto
sbagliato tasto e sas e di sopra
perfette di sopra stiamo tranquilli
daimi sfonda la porta son cazzi
come si fa devo spegnere la torcia non è
che se avete la torcia si capisce che
sono qui raga come cazzo faccio ho paura
raga ho paura che noi fa hanno risolto
ma vai muoviti muoviti
ok aprì la porta prima portava i cori
adesso che ci siamo dov'è ok a safe
combination found che cazzo vuol dire ho
trovato una combinazione una
combinazione di cosa vabbè stampa mi
l'occhio vai
ok dov'è fatemi capire bike e fai che
valdisotto fa che se cioè andata di
sotto
che culo bene allora premo qua muoviti
muoviti prima che torni perfetta orly
brutto stronzo è una cosa impossibile
bene ci siamo perché c'è gandalf
dobbiamo che cazzo ci fa gandalf lì
ci sono anche i tuoni fai come se non
bastasse è passato qualcuno non lo so
non voglio saperlo andiamo avanti
accordi perfetto ci siamo
entriamo qui dentro stiamo entrando in
zone a caso ma spero di trovare i
sacchetti che servono quanto siamo raga
verso il conto completamente insieme a 9
ok
dove cazzo andata e sempre di stoffa che
sia risorse e di nuovi di brutto stop
che vai
ci siamo devo entrare in porta a caso
questa era quella di prima ho sbagliato
ce ne aveva una possibilità ci avevano
sbagliato ok non so più dove devo andare
lago perche quanti cazzo di sacchetti
c'erano una volta adesso non ce n'è più
neanche uno prima era pieno
ok è diventato un gioco imprese perfetto
consenso 12 vai e vai siamo a 11 ragazzi
amo più di metà ce la posso fare
ce la posso fare credere in me so che
non ci crede nessuno tanto però va beh
io ci ho provato
dove ha tratto ceo di mettere un
sacchetto e di sotto ma possiamo farcela
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye 13 3
brutto stronzo salta vai vai vai dove
era troppo equa perfetto fa che ce ne
siano 25 di sacchetti qui 12 vabbè già
qualcosa
braga mi mancano cinque sacchetti
il problema è che non è da lì dove
andare a prenderli
dov'è la tv non c'è neanche più l'occhio
fantastico non ho più un cazzo devo
andare alla cieca e non vedo nulla non
fa neanche più rumore quando passa
quindi se passa io non la vedo neanche
non dedizione
è un problema questo era già perché
puntarmi all'improvviso aiuto cazzo
torno indietro di corri corri corri
corri corri ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta
non ci credo non ci voglio credere
madonna che ansia
raga io non voglio riuscire ragalo
saperla me darò guardate io me le mando
sempre lo so però è così cazzo non ci
posso credere
cioè si puntata proprio quando sono
uscito una precisione assurda ma devo
ritrovarmela di nuovo no non devo dirlo
perché poi mi porto sfiga ma all'inizio
mi porto sfiga
vabbè di domandare di sotto la gamba
anche se so che più o meno
penso sarà 18 no non è di solito che
culo ecco assurdo
ok siamo al 16 raga ne mancano 4 ce la
posso fare
ne mancano tre mi manca blocco no no no
no no no corri porca [ __ ]
raga non ce la faccio è troppo difficile
è l'anno hanno aumentato la difficoltà
pensate che norma è difficoltà normale
questa perché se non c'è anche modalità
difficile draga è impossibile
e finito a cazzo scusate bene ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto lo speciale
100 video
voglio ringraziarvi ancora di cuore per
tutti mi piace che lasciate sempre sotto
ogni video per tutti i commenti per
tutti i complimenti che mi fate
veramente grazie infinite prima di
chiudere vorrei soltanto annunciarvi una
cosa ragazzi adesso si sta avvicinando
il mese di maggio è il mese essendo io
un essere umano e dato che vado a scuola
il mese di maggio è molto diciamo
tempestato di verifiche interrogazioni e
cose del genere
quindi raga è possibile che ci siano dei
giorni qui non metto video o dei giorni
qui video ritardano può essere nel mese
di maggio è il mese più infernale per
per gli studenti se siete studenti anche
voi lo sapete e quindi raga veramente mi
scuso in anticipo se in futuro potrà
capitare che non metterò video tutti i
giorni ovviamente per il mese di maggio
è perché poi in estate ripartiamo in
quarta però per dire per il mese di
maggio purtroppo sono molto limitato
cercherò di fare il possibile
detto questo vi ringrazio ancora una
volta per il traguardo incredibile è
come al solito se vi do vi è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bella
ragazza